how's it going resumes pip welcome back
to some more kitch patty in the black
baby well I don't [ __ ] know I don't
know maybe we gotta get a home get a hoe
go what is this
what if this what if that's what mutton
did this can I go down make sure she's
not there I don't know no girl rival a
man out there I don't even know you know
ya know so that really was hurt well I
guess we know that now but I'm thinking
maybe it wasn't her when okay I'm by
Bernie stupid I'm sorry maybe we should
salami tamales oh god what is going on
now found [ __ ] d9 up come on up
well I don't remember come on come on
goddamn it
yeah one more chance come on all right
yes come on
oh thank god that was close man sewage a
scene over yeah yes she's all good
another betting you some CP oh you take
the liver there oh you speak real that's
not how you blow inside someone else
mouth Oh a worry oh well never mind in
they can't she buys us Ania
what the hell does she do anyway
gorgeously the car
lovely booty we gonna resell my off how
about from now and you don't split up I
think that's a good idea
you got it to decide I need a doctor
oh boy Dan Aikido yasutora me no my go
mama Derrida see no no Connie pi Remo
Remo she Osaka domicile girl - ah yeah
Penang Carla all right well let's pump
it out then honey
algae the show enemies a good I know
well doubt it something I don't like
this
yeah take the one with a broken crane
yeah well do it wine table who's a
Chianti don't don't don't don't go there
Joshy key be nicer hair alright Ettore
eyes etomidate cut other Auto Tomica see
that yeah that's my joshie key my gosh
are you kabocha welcome make it all yes
ego that's adorable
Otto dado cut if cool caucus on I do nah
mother wet anyway
do that I'm silver here forgive me
general here Madonna yeah I'm definitely
for the best
no more splitting up all right I'm tired
of that [ __ ] every time they split up
goddamnit
alright you know what let's let's go so
so far the only character that actually
died is Seiko I'm surprised I thought
like one person would die in every
chapter but I guess that would be too
obvious we need
nothing got stocked this time I lays so
disgusting
there we go
dead poeple everywhere I'm not a fan of
dead poeple hello there it's the body of
a female student thank you Mitsuki cami
Choi patchwork of puzzles can zu
keysight oh thank you Kazuki Saito based
on and squad MS it's Erina Tanaka thank
you your innate Tanaka and thank you
Tsukasa to rota oh we can go here
perhaps dim lights around you are
reflecting out there something deep
inside the draining great try to fish it
out I don't have a fishing rod with me
handle huh well you never know when you
can use one
oh god that's nasty missus I remember
the wheel from the water pump and threw
it into the foot I removed okay
hopefully that'll keep anyone from
finding the little treasure I left in
the spigot that [ __ ] killed my friends
she can spend eternity without a tongue
for all I care oh so they stole they
stole the tongue oh my god oh my god
maybe here
a crude label written on a piece of tape
attached to the device reads water pump
right below it there's a slot for some
sort of lever oh my god
fantástico brochacho it's fantastical i
squatted it devel module all right we
got it
we nailed it now what um I don't
hello I don't understand what oh it was
inside their copious amount of blood it
seems I've fallen from the spigot oh
that's a spigot an elementary school a
student egg name tag attached
to keep goats Uji the bag appears to
contain severed human tongue Oh God not
this [ __ ] again
what is this the new pokemons freaky
Japanese alright well let's give her at
our tongue back as opposed I don't even
know she lost a tongue oh the girl
obviously which is of course you're the
girl right Africa oh no she wanted the I
[ __ ] come with coochie-coochie
[ __ ] there you go
a lot of tongues don't you girls spirit
Dipple at the time bag yes
goddamn this is so [ __ ] up
her little girl spared is staggering
towards IU means blood gushing up from
her gasping cross-section headed she was
placed be the right one oh [ __ ]
she's pest we have to find her I how do
we find her I girl how do we find that
agar I were running this way love
running this way this my February oh
[ __ ] gosh darn it
she went this way let's check it out
girl what's happening Oh God not this
[ __ ] again
mother cool da do go that did not stop
crying all right tell us where the is
well your friend was splat oh come on
Wow Wow
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] up man oh my god
nice
my dad would okay then
no I doubt I don't write uh big she's
[ __ ] Charlie with us isn't she
alright then maybe maybe we maybe I
don't know me maybe should get some
gloves
oh oh oh alright nightmares thank you
thank you very much oh god that's creepy
punch it in the deck who's like a male
sannin y'all so mother honey I wanna
okay wait okay oh but it's not her we
know that right
daughter guy you don't oka oh god it's a
sicko boost oh yeah sima sore any angel
soldier amo burden on you you're gonna
dig it out oh my god
Oh yuck tone aha oh my dog una dama de
california dan doctor sake CUNY Kiyoshi
not a Matata he got satara nan kikuchiyo
huey kiyokawa Tita mahoto Mucha too much
Donna I'm Oh Tony Mateo oh hi it's Nam
Abruzzi Naga hmm Nong Khai mo toga ha
great a tummy tuck it all what do you
say kick good sir
Daniel you already dug it out didn't he
Oh
oh my god what a mucus today first-class
psycho get on the kiddo
Ronnie can imagine I call air y las
Cuates Tokyo or AHIMA esto sagasta sir a
dokuro Channel
well that went better than expected
thank you appreciate it
you kick I know the last one yeah
Nando angel solo mio you know when the
glass is flare up like that that's when
you know you don't [ __ ] with them soda
muchas de y know Eddie Machado society
today oh they did say that oh oh my god
ee-aw I'm guessing what this is module
are you are no buses are not there
shikaku know you can e demo crew got
that under ah cool mmm she Bobby deduct
I've normal I mean how else would he got
him in out
let's um
I guess the spread will be up here right
hope is the right one
you never know that yeah it is of course
it is you bros ready for this [ __ ] sick
of you and your attitude main goddamn
even I stuck it a boo-boo
what is that tiny 1000 tongue I thought
you wanted an eye oh [ __ ] she needs a
night I'm sorry
oh yeah yeah yeah you're welcome again
space that's it yeah yeah Thomas you
like a good story oh you deserve it
Poland evolution it's got a dick Knesset
that was last one okay Honda chabela
synagogue ah-ha-ha Malone Akane I'll get
it took on the colonel who talk much
ouch well shinozaki
well kotappa Sookie Oregon yeah girl
Dada wait there's more I thought there
were three goody
what oh no no no no no no no nooooo oh
not again what is going on oh god it's
him he's pissed off right now
shoosh not a taco no Dada hmm what a
freaky freak her maker did we make it
back alive are we back in the classroom
oh really
Scottish oil they made it
Oh us tada
see you like it boy Oh kiddo y'all
how did that happen
meet Amy doyle-murray hey what about
Cindy Hamlin back at all I don't believe
it
it's still good to be truth huh maybe
nine must die all
hoorah little squibber awkward laughs
and sign up now go kiss a kinda like a
demoted
come on McCann already come on Soto Jia
you sense it as well cut it in nail yeah
maybe we should wait maybe we shouldn't
wait for them Soto Jia Yu is is it just
click on the door like that venturing
out in search of the others you find
that even the janitor was like Logano
lights are out and also pitch black only
the red glow of the light next to the
fire extinguisher offers any respite
from quaint quiet darkness of the school
hallway Hodges you'll see Tim expanding
around in Akane no guru cotinine Allah
as a thunder and rain grow in intensity
the window begins to condensate with
moisture turning white in contrast to
the corridor sea of black
that's beautiful describe gingered Scott
Kenji Bowden Wang you made of touch and
I go no do that
Nonya tender water I don't know
those are silly don't you [ __ ] [ __ ]
with me mother of [ __ ] what is that
what is that y'all come on nice that
[ __ ] oh my god what do you want
the hell does that mean Oh Oh cousin
don't take calls this my master didn't
it's lesson
welcome Nihal gossip oh no you're not oh
but that's not your guy that's me
what did you do oh but that Edo gonna
check on them I musta so shut up that's
not Anatomy yes but there's no Hana
Sookie did it done again gobo nothing I
do get up go get it on Mary Cain man huh
you liked him huh
my DD do
no well no [ __ ]
yeah you better listen poor girl
thank you have you got the what I said
I'd Allah best at you
so what does that good at that
Jake you look Joe what's up Victorville
yeah tell us why wait we [ __ ] up
because we didn't have her eyes he do I
go to stir hey buddy
here to sell a house that's not doable
to me you dissing you do that I don't
you and what is it I need to advise upon
I then you don't I stay but does the
tikka dingy super cool igloo gonna touch
accommodated rich oh no dumb bender
gotta weigh in Yokosuka puto bud oh yes
die nan deo non-data Mukhin Kano ninguém
o hanuman Animoto geometer na loretta to
Ascanio vo suit ah no ah no it is cool
no unit come on we know your day guitar
hey calm down
Google tonight it don't matter how good
a many scenic what
samoto guru says Anika uh no she didn't
huh let's go sicko sometimes lucky them
on the scene you gonna do you got
Douglass safety Nandi Cooney a cottage
cheese kiona I got a Sunday Oh Anita
Nikita koto bar what c ome Rio no costa
mama
bori ok techie Nino chose accessory
Tirico the Louis two-day you tokura no
saccharine Ichiko you tied a todo
Montezuma you don't knock on door oh my
god Osama's any naughty samar thiru Cara
hold on a sec kakarotto zan only Tamia
techie Nakamoto contoured a kidney can
toggle kuru kuru cut it - Oh mine on
maison de daño show apparently don't you
quit snow hole Nativity ha ha yep guy
who can like tell me no mo Takuya said
that's more gonna take target get on
this ah hmm
why I know gamma toxin or Ngong can I
know till Papa second hasta so good is
Shin da da da da I mean on Inga
there's no room there the stop buzzer
goody no God Betty sale but should I
Hajj Emad Amos Oh
each data store
Thomas audits and also Duggan wandering
in addition Amos
Oh Myka toss the Korean economy
Tara what's the Pentecostal ii Adina
well thank God
duels and ale or needs almost a to hold
it now come on
Angie's yogic wanna Dido your man you
good me now silver specifically liver
how good ammo should not die good gun
it sounds impassable it's no wave quit
Mononoke home oh we're not really home
anyway so de sica kono karada history
righto Mota Tanya son dad Sabrina Oh
Maris animo Jobo to stay Nakata co2
estás aquí y como Tom Oh yo boots techie
Nakata yeah - Edina nada Shanna tell me
everything
Jurgis spare gently took hold of I in
his hand and in an instant their two
beings seem to merge together into
single mind
ah okay then thank you for doing that
couldn't she have gone with a boy I
guess it's weird to have a PPE don't
know what Jesus the Stars not only is
Kegel Odyssey Corot okole danke
score a touch okay Nina cannot chiavari
me ty oh my god Oh what is this
uncle game buddy you eat Zeki nokotta
Agawam pieces
aha such Kanaka suppose I can go o
biryani taka with stated oh sorry Terry
Oh dorita pony coma she knows a chicken
is eaten killa sua
konna koto garaje tocino surya donkey no
toko meet mo nanio me Tamia Tornai
sangguk a no-go Titan Attica koya gay
coach oh no choke on a knee or a saison
a honk OH
so no SK and Arsenal hay quien SE jose
enemy no creo me Cano cheese on a
seasoned sammich Oh Sheila arose Oconee
not an Eau de vato yo so stow nada soda
Anika daremo Sachiko no sono go
todo rocoto Hideki Naga Tom de todo con
la Seabury neo Tantra yoga Castellano
coke a Grammy arrow that's a tree Aden
Casino Connie o tok oh no coca story
Connie
yo voy a gar nah ha no hana yo Rosarita
10d so no Kodomo tachi da letto poet a
sea of comb a minute ears Yossi beretta
Takara
poetess no karada Babu kana lokasya
right Sam this is so [ __ ] up
that's some nice Japanese right there
now come on mekong cosa de nani mo me ni
te a samosa VAR re taro crow me CAC Co
Turkish crew stair Tokyo ho Amiga Tondo
beam cannon Armani no katachi lui toast
you okay what the [ __ ] hey maverick
cassava is Cuba
non Japan Tonto Tonto Tonto click I see
toto
max1 wonderful una loca Nohemi gaga and
follow me on Facebook
how about what a nice Hayek oh yeah
Mon you gotta like you know tony garea
Kunekune east Agata yeah cut they're
gone sorry
Giotto so Barto seis y car Astana choreo
- Murari tyonna en este gear any not a
Anoka nice da Mucha lucha nameko perrito
ha
tangina hakuna Keiko toes come on
Express today you querida touch daughter
to a king are a king saryati no game
baba ma San Samba Kumar say sonic
okidata
Hashimoto Sonu Kakkar keo keo Tahoe
genie an ingot any stata okie Natasha
kielbasa me to Dante Chucho matança vato
cognomen on Easter Kurumi Nakada scosh
Sione satsui amo te Hong Kong un de puta
Haku Delta Qashqai happy Ottawa G
dota-chin Shiva Stokke literary Takata
Nagi said she was dicenio-- moto no
motor see Coco go Connery Tito Wow
Nikola scenery media dejado sorry Tina
Satsuma new Tabata gamba de San Jacomo
gusta search console guinea moto
Citterio hey a sushi bar a macaque
co-citation a sriracha storage zoo
choryo a Tanaka sorry
Jen Bunney chorus Arteta story wall
Kissimmee def couvreux Metazoa sorry
tavini Tokyo knocked or a
Sakshi manager sky stone Connie sauces
numerator
Studio hoes am ii desuyo Kenyatta for
Saturday
Chikara when you gonna send a news
jesus H cracks why why Jimmy D Nokia
hasami oat any potassium euros tato sack
you know Cody guanaco Torah Rhetta
Kodomo tachi what Karim Akbari somata
second on a holiday - Gnomeo miss kita
kita - hasta so no so litochoro por una
nota seem Amira no Sakura
No
story whoa-ho Sameera Cancun on tomosa
sorry tavini supona units every tomato
soup like what the freshman Rita Sweeney
skits Anita Sanogo Nausicaa Honua
son in Oita Cora Stowe Hamid SS - dear
spits Astaire watashi mo moany noir
Canada was an Akuma Sergio del dedo son
mingott Ansel sorry rueake you eat Zeki
nokotta Zozo Sachiko Nikita carrucan
Ojinaga Ankara suicune Esme yashka Zozo
keen Sarita Iike Eleonora Carrillo
Hannon coq10 Wakanda Chauhan Mindy or
Cano Genoa Jetta con muchos mo Kazuko
same Oh Issei no quiero chrono go Tina
yo yo Yori Akira Eva Suns aesthetic on
Sakina matekoni Noda kogo korabik
acetone enol oddest a broken Tony
you're scottson Hong Kong yeah
see dota 2 SATs Gaston or wantoniy OS
Kozma
otineru SCARA photo Bonnie or eaten in
tono contact Oh a few geodata to ie
kihon techie neo tanoshiku panini
kingyoku Ariana says Devon Agata Korea
Carillo Travis involve any o Kings o
menos o game of judoma dick tompa cappa
Zen con una cocconi Hasid Oregon I know
Debra Ipoh sore American code êtes-vous
cousin chuyia Yanagi horikoshi Matteson
chicane again TOEIC auditory hajimeta no
mo Nani kana torus carrot Ione
yes Kanaka vitamin E in if menno can
generate so Coquina battery animo no
kaneo biryani Janos me Nico Marie avoid
a vomit a laboratory Jose Ramos o
dhananjaya not eat cat GM Yasuo jin-seok
waited screen on go Chi Chi koto show
hey so sorry theta
10 jin songa qanats Cassini consider
nanika o Kenan or oh no Sanjay Khan or
ENSO code Edo yokai Satsuki
surah nisa Conover Bhutto Murugan Agra
sincerity Macario vomits katha un icon
in Otago g4e cosas de baisemeaux cocoon
etat arrogance I do you señorita 10 jin
songa cannot sky stotra berkutov cana da
da ba da CA Osasuna yo me bouquet
hohoemi GA dekita greater Marinette
Canoga Connaughton or commotion a curry
or e so no june minute ago kuru kuru
squirrel chicken Renzo Anita would stage
title what is that like an x-factor what
AHA
continually Chapter five [ __ ] ah sorry
Jesus that was a lot of [ __ ] pecs man
that was awesome though I guess we have
a lot to figure out in Chapter five last
chakra Bruce are you ready I said all
you ready that's better
go ahead and even like you enjoy
watching Bruce that's always thank you
so much for doing so thank you so much
for watching I'll see you tomorrow
stammers I'm you